as Iraq slips deeper into political
crisis the one man Iraqis look to for
guidance is silent Grand Ayatollah Ali
al-sistani Friday sermon delivered
through his representative usually
includes comments on political matters
closely watched in streets and halls of
government alike this week the cleric
announced he'd no longer speak on
political issues and he passed a cryptic
message to Iraq spa laticious explaining
why if you read history you'll find that
the problem is not with the people who
have wisdom and intellect but with those
who don't listen to those who have
wisdom and intellect clerics close to
Sistani say his silence is a show of
this may that Iraq's politicians are not
heeding his advice sustain his reclusion
comes at a critical time on Thursday
president bar ham Saleh said he would
rather resign then appoint the nominee
for prime minister Asad Ali Danny seen
as representing the status quo tomorrow
Molitor alkalyn through the earth what
is the point of talking on political
issues we are repeating the same points
over and over again if they want to get
advice they'll find it in previous
speeches it's not the first time Sistani
has done this he stopped making
political speeches temporarily in 2013
and 2016 to put pressure on political
leaders and the majid min when he finds
a response in rapid progress towards
early elections based on the recently
passed law when he finds a little
response he will resume give him
political advice Sistani may have also
grown tired of his words being used to
meet political ends to fossil political
forces dissect the steps of Sistani and
interpret them according to their
interests
my job has seen some of the worst
violence since demonstrations began here
- protesters have set up camp in the
central square determined to stay until
their demands are met they feel
encouraged by Sistani support but unless
there is a complete overhaul of the
political system they doubt that early
elections a priority for Sistani will
bring meaningful change the choice is
made by the politicians we want Prime
Minister and a president to be elected
by the people Frank Ayatollah Ali
al-sistani is implicit endorsement is
seen as necessary for the nomination of
a new prime minister and his decision to
no longer comment on political
developments is regarded as pressuring
political parties to choose someone
protesters can accept but his silence
also creates a leadership vacuum that
some fear could worsen the crisis
similar 14 al Jazeera Najaf